This is the Chris Abraham show.
Welcome to The Chris Abraham
Show Episode 4 Season 10.
My name is Chris Abraham, and I
know that there's a lot of news
to discuss.
And I know that I should be
talking about Iran and I know I
should be talking about State of
the Union, and I know I should
be talking about a million other
things.
But on the media was just on
WAMU, and it was a it was an
apology for democracy and the
value of public media.
And I have opinions on that
because I have a hard time
listening to NPRWAMU and I am a
lifer.
I started listening to WAMU ever
since I was ever since I was 23.
I mean, I listened to it when I
was a weak kid, but my parents
listened to it, right?
So, you know Garrison Keillor
listening to Garrison Keillor on
the way home from North Shore,
coming back to Salt Lake,
Honolulu and the in the the
family automobile, sleepy in the
evening, night time outside
crossing pineapple fields or
sugar cane fields or whatever.
And I remember that kind of like
during the liminal space between
waking and sleeping and Car Talk
as a child and everything else.
But when I graduated from
college, I got my first
apartment and I listened to a
lot of radio, and it was WAMU
88.5 FM.
And that was the first time I
thought maybe I should have gone
to American University instead
of GW, because AMU is American
University and they are the
university that sponsors and
hosts the NPR station, the talk
only NPR station in DC.
Although when I started back in
the 90s, there was actually
bluegrass and there was all
other kinds of things.
There was there was folk music.
It was it was a different world.
Now it's all now it is all now
it is all talk radio all the
time.
So I was listening to on the
media and it was fascinating
because, you know, they consider
our democracy A flawed democracy
and European Western democracies
is good democracies.
But now I have unlocked the
cheat code.
Democracy means compliant.
Democracy means compliant and in
line with messaging.
Because every single European
country that I know in the West
except for maybe the UK, seems
to be, well, less and less.
But when I was living there in
the mid 2000s, late 2000s, it
was a high trust environment.
And when I lived in Berlin,
which of course had its own NPR,
American NPR station there,
USUSNPRI could listen to Wait,
Wait, Don't Tell Me via the
airwaves from my apartment in
Moabit.
But I think democracy only means
compliant with the will of the
aristocracy.
Because if you if you are
populist or you don't agree, or
you opt out, or you treat try to
redefine or you try to move
right or you have questions,
then you might be considered a
flawed democracy.
So it doesn't seem very
democratic where democracy has
been Co opted and redefined as
whether or not the people are
compliant with the media
messaging and the direction of
the long arc of democracy in the
long arc arc of justice etcetera
and this kind of denial of
people's opinion.
I think that if if public radio,
we're still in the hands of
people like Mr. Rogers, I don't
think even Donald Trump would be
able to defund public media.
I think that the left or if you
will, the official message, the
official direction, the the
official narrative of American,
I don't know, justice and future
and democracy is countermanded
to aggressively right.
Like my dad, who was a who was a
very charming drunk, sat me down
one day to teach me how to drive
his 1974 Triumph TR 6 drunk.
And he said that the biggest
problem that drunks make is they
drive too slowly and they tend
to oversteer.
And I think that the moment a
populist government, the moment
there is a right wing influence,
the moment there is a white
blood cell inflammation reaction
to the current direction of the
liberal democracy, is the moment
people steer too hard to the
left.
And what it does is it makes
people on the right steer too
hard to the right, and it makes
people on the right realize that
they don't have control of the
car at all.
And it makes them desperate to
get control back of the car.
And that throws off everything.
And a lot of it has to do with
the trust vector, right?
America has historically
distrusted government, all
government, state, local,
federal, all government, the
pigs, the man, the tax man, the
Fed, even the damn, you know,
local constable, sheriff,
etcetera.
Everybody hates the pigs.
And by definition everybody
hates the the man.
And by by definition everybody
hates the government.
So you have to win people.
So it has to be a charm
offensive.
And once it goes from carrot to
stick, the the silent majority
gets pissed and realizes you
call that a stick.
This here's a stick.
And the moment the the
neutralness or perceived value
of public radio, if it looks
like it's being weaponized
against Donald Trump or, or
republicanism or MAGA or
populism or anti migration or
anything that feels anti
establishment disguised as anti
establishment, people are going
to react.
People are going to react.
And this facade of democracy
being the will of the people is
bizarre.
Whenever anybody gladly calls a
country democratic, they are
actually saying compliant with
the goals and visions of their
government, not sui generis.
No, no, we need to react to the
situation happening at our
borders or within our priorities
or being captured by leftists or
by alt cultures or or
immigration or other languages
or tribalism or anything that
makes them feel like maybe they
are not steering the car.
The moment people become aware
that they're in fact, is it
little Maggie?
Yeah, once if they ever realize
that their little Maggie using
the fake steering wheel and not
Marge actually driving the car,
people get really angry.
So, I mean, people would gladly
pay a 5 percent, 6% tax if they
thought that the kind of quality
programming that Germany and
England and so forth provide for
their local people, such as
educational programming.
I mean, literally in in England
and in Germany, they offer on TV
and radio.
They teach you languages, they
teach you math, they teach you
algebra, they'll teach you
history.
You'll actually get credits if
you go through the process and
gives an opportunity for people
to learn to enculturate.
There's a value add.
And it doesn't seem like there
is a constant desire to dunk on
the actually democratically
elected, popularly elected,
democratically elected,
Electoral College elected and
swing state elected president of
the United States, his cabinet,
his executive and his Senate and
even his Supreme Court.
I mean, you can define whether
it's his or not, but it's
definitely his executive and his
vision for America.
If you go ahead and you say put
your hands over your ears and
go, I can't hear you, I can't
hear you, I'm not going to
update my orders until the next
Democrat comes in.
Don't be surprised when your NGO
gets shuttered or you lose your
retirement because you are
summarily fired and removed from
your 20 years in the job that
you honestly thought you could
never be fired from.
I mean, it just seems so obvious
that you have to make
concessions and you just have to
extend your goals.
If you want to turn the world
into a, a liberal utopia,
Marxist, globalist democracy,
you're going to have to put it
off for four years or eight
years or 12 years or 16 years.
Not everything is always going
to work out.
There's way more people who are
boring normie breeders who think
anything that's not completely
normal.
Normie breeders are just
generally gay and they don't
like that.
They'll tolerate it, they don't
like it.
They're fine with it being in
their family, but they don't
want to base an entire culture
on LGBTQIA or autistic spectrum
disorder or anything else like
that.
So I mean, it's so easy to
predict.
And the behavior of the first
administration under Trump was a
was like a shot over the bow.
I mean, honestly, people were
extremely amazed that Twitter
and Facebook etcetera, etcetera,
etcetera could remove, could
actually remove a president,
sitting president from social
media and that a full time job
of all radio programs except
maybe Newsmax and Washington
Times and New York Post and Fox
News, maybe Daily Wire, Daily
Caller.
But the rest of them were, you
know, disobey, deny.
People were just not taking
orders in federal government non
profit Ng OS even under the
executive umbrella.
People were literally slow
walking things.
They were being defiant.
And of course, you know, DOGE.
Doge was very quickly weaponized
against every single person
who's ever said anything via
probably text message, Slack,
WhatsApp, whatever, including
emails that actually said I
hereby am ignoring what Donald
Trump is telling me to do.
Do I have your approval?
Upper management and all of that
was figured out with AI and
every single one of those people
were fired as as ignoring orders
as being defiant and literally
not following direct orders.
So that happened and then people
are still licking their wounds,
right?
Like USAID and so many other
things and sanctuary cities are
losing their medic, Medicaid,
Medicare, sanctuary states,
sanctuary cities.
I mean, there's a lot of literal
things that an executive who's
not even remotely appeased or in
any way respected can single
handedly, without any requests
or appeal, make decisions at the
pleasure of himself.
So I mean, that happened.
I mean, I don't know how long
the I don't know how long the
damage will be done.
I mean, we still don't know if a
Democrat will win in 2028.
We don't know if JD Vance or
Marco Rubio or maybe Pelcy
Gabbard comes back or it's going
to be AOC or it's going to be
Newsom, Gavin Newsom, or if
it'll be the dude from Philly.
I'd vote for that dude.
But like, it's really kind of,
it's kind of, it was honestly
public media.
They weren't assassinated.
They committed suicide.
I mean, it was suicide by cop.
It was suicide by Trump, but it
was done through hubris and
pride and arrogance and vanity
and envy.
And it was every single mortal,
what is it called?
Every single mortal venal sin
was perpetrated by the left and
and they fucked around and found
out and it just seems so obvious
to me.
I will link to the to the on the
media episode.
I mean on the media is such a
great resource for anybody
because it's like insider
trading.
On the media always tells
everybody what's going to happen
the next 1 to 8 weeks with
regards to there's this idea of
influencer, right?
There's this idea of influencer,
there's this idea of
intellectualism and Academy and
so forth.
There's this idea of who
influences the public, but
there's also this idea of who
influences the influencer.
And it's generally more niche.
And On the media is definitely
an influencer of the
influencers.
There's a lot of podcasts that
do that, but there are very few
mainstream, mainstream NPR
products.
And when Donald Trump became
president, on the media went
from being an obscure 6:00 AM
during Biden on the media was
relegated to 6:00 AM on really
weird days like 6:00 AM Saturday
morning and 5:00 AM on Sunday.
And you know, 6:00 PM on Friday
or whatever and the moment
Donald Trump came on board on
the media got prime time because
there is a desire to forget with
vibration mode on the alarm and
we need to make it full on
whoop, whoop, whoop, whoop,
whoop, whoop.
So I don't know, there's a lot
of impotence on the left.
There's a lot of be clowning of
oneself.
There's obviously other things
I've discussed such as doubling
down and becoming less populist
and becoming more exclusive and
becoming more elite and more
obscure and more LGBTQIA and
doubling down on on identity
politics, Doubling down on
counterculture, doubling down on
intelligentsia, doubling down on
European envy and desire to
have.
I mean, it's so obvious.
The funny thing is, is that
everybody envies the
parliamentary styles so that you
can actually get people through
coalitions into the prime
ministership who are extremely
well educated and beautiful,
acceptable technocrats with
amazing pedigree and degrees and
acceptable beliefs and
leadership.
But people forget that MAGA is
literally using American
democracy like a coalition
government.
Anybody who wasn't under the
parasol of the left, which like
I said is really just what I
like to call is, is liberal chic
or Marxist chic or a radical
chic.
That's the term.
You know, the kind of the kind
of elite people who invite Black
Panthers to their to their
salons and think that they're so
edgy because they know Black
Panthers and they want to share
that with all their friends.
But literally everybody laughs
at them because they're so out
of touch.
And you go ahead and do like
daps and you do knuckle bumps
and you do handshakes with them
for the cameras.
Then you roll your eyes so they
can't see you, but you know that
they're going to fund you, at
least until they're distracted
by another moral imperative.
So they can put their money
there and be associated with
free Palestine or climate, or
they can be associated with ICE.
Ice.
The reason why I say ICE is I
use voice to text a lot and
whenever I say ice it's just all
lowercase.
If you can hear that I'm running
this through Adobe Enhance, so
maybe you're not going to hear
that, but if you hear that
emergency response vehicle, it's
a fire, fire truck going down
Columbia Pike in sexy S
Arlington, VA.
If you could hear that in the
background, I want you to know
that that's the sound I was
talking about when it comes to
the left, completely setting off
the alarm, saying this is an
existential threat.
We don't like the fact that all
of the presidential powers that
really benefited Obama and Biden
are being used against the left
and all that other stuff.
I mean if if I were to call the
last 10 years and give it a name
instead of the golden age I
would call it the faffo age the
fuck around and find out age.
Both the left and the right have
done an amazing job of fucking
around and finding out.
And on that note, I will stone
my tinfoil hat till the next
time.
And I hope you enjoyed season 10
episode 4 of The Chris Abraham
Show.
I hope this sounds OK and it is
a beautiful day in sexy S
Arlington.
It is 54°F on a komulgi on a
March 1st year of our Lord 2026.
And I'm getting sun.
And I actually took a lip balm
that I use, which is a general
balm.
And I saw how nasty and how
chalky and how ashy my arms and
legs are out in the sun.
And I actually did something
known as skin care.
So I had Starbucks breakfast and
now I'm heading to do some work
at Arlington Columbia Pike
Library until they close at 1700
hours and then I'll try to do
from 5:00 to 9:00 at Starbucks
because to me Sunday is the Oh
no, look at all the things I
didn't do because I was spending
too much time on Facebook.
Oh, as an aside, for whatever
reason I forgot to do do a
little check mark on Facebook
that allowed me to actually make
money from being a complete
Facebook content sharing slut.
So now I'm actually, you know,
who knows, I might ascend to
subsidizing my lavish lifestyle
with money coming directly from
meta.
So I predict in my crystal ball,
I predict that going forward I'm
going to be even more
promiscuous, more slutty, and
even shamelesser.
Even more shameless.
And what else?
What else?
I was going to say something
else.
Como dia, como dia.
Well, that's it for now.
I think that's enough.
Oh, I'm still doing Meshtastic.
I love it.
I figured out how to turn off
Bluetooth connected to the Wi-Fi
router.
And so immediately when I enter
my apartment, I'm immediately
connected back to the little H3
Helltech Meshtastic device.
And I renamed my mestastic
device from Abra named after
myself Abracadabra.
I called it Abraham, and then I
called it Abracadabra.
And now I named it to ARHI.
And I named the node Arlington
Heights because I think it's
more useful to have a router
late as a named node.
As to where it is physically and
what else, I don't know what
else.
That's it for now.
Oh, for those of you who are
worried about my heart, I I got
a second ablation and that has
given me reliable sinus rhythm,
so that is awesome.
The only thing now I need to
radically lose the equivalent of
any girl I dated during the 90s
and 2000s.
That's how much body weight I
need to remove from my
corpulent, corpulent, beautiful
body.
On that note, I will be checking
off now and I hope you enjoyed
it and I will talk to you soon.
Don't forget to like, subscribe,
share, recommend, comment,
review and all those other
things.
Talk to you soon.
Mahalo and much love.
Bye bye.
Thank you for listening to The
Chris Abraham Show.
Make sure you subscribe so you
don't miss any future episodes.
Until next time.